[Music]
[Applause]
hello my goran party people and welcome
to the honest trailer
for firefly i am spencer j gilbert
that's joe
that's lawn today we're talking about
our honest trailer for as we mentioned
firefly
we're going to be uh talking about our
thought process maybe getting a little
deeper into the jokes
as we watch the trail together then we
will watch some deleted scenes then
we're going to respond to comments and
questions from viewers like you you all
know the drill
um uh this week was a long requested
long-awaited one
a show that was before its time and paid
the price
firefly oh yeah yeah
a good show i think you all know the the
the basic gist of it
one one uh cursed season on fox um
where they aired it out of order uh it
kept getting bumped for
baseball games and um some adam sandler
movie
that got better ratings it was then
summarily cancelled
and has lived on in the hearts of
convention goers ever since
um joe you're the biggest firefly fan
here
what's your firefly relationship uh
i like this show i can't pretend to not
like firefly i think
joss whedon's stuff is interesting where
it either really works or it really does
not
um buffy really works dollhouse really
does not
firefly really works avenger really
works uh
age of ultron question mark justice
league really did not
so i i like just that formula he's got
either
it's a home run or it's not and i feel
like with firefly uh the formula really
works
uh the the talent that's matched to it
uh
really runs with it um
and you know we we get it into it in the
trailer but i honestly i think part of
the appeal
and part of what makes this show work is
that it got cancelled
and you just have this one little uh
amount of time
with these characters where they're all
still just fresh
and uh near and dear uh before the show
starts making any creative missteps
yeah mon what about you uh yeah i was
not a huge fan like i loved buffy so i
would always
check out whatever new joss whedon show
there was gonna be because i was like
maybe this will be new buffet and i
i tended to be let down uh and so i was
not i sort of stopped watching this
maybe after a few episodes when it was
first
airing going back now re-watching it
actually seeing it in order this was the
first time i like
went through and i'm gonna just watch
firefly like binge it like in a week and
watch the whole thing
i i enjoyed it i enjoyed it more than i
did the first time i think
i think time has healed a lot of the
things that irked me about it when it
was new
i think obviously these are fun
characters and good
actors and like it's fun to see these
performances and so i yeah i actually
enjoyed it
and like the stuff that bugged me the
first time through like the obviously
budgetary limitations and the fact that
it is kind of
doing this larger story but very
episodic in the early run like i enjoyed
that this time whereas it sort of
frustrated me
uh the first time through one thing i
will say that i really appreciate that
he did
is you he purposefully i mean obviously
he thought he was gonna get to come back
and make more seasons
but he there's no attempt to like even
try to like
wrap things up because it's the end of
the first season like right
you just kind of end on this note of
like there's changes there's some
place setting for future seasons but not
really you don't get any of the big
answers and i like
now looking back i really admire the
patience to like not show us the reavers
really in season one and like
not get into like what's shepard's
real backstory like you only get little
hints at it and
i i appreciate that now looking back
yeah yeah
i think the cancellation came deep
enough into filming that there was no
time to
course correct i mean that's what the
movie's all about right um
to kind of uh bring things to a close
which i actually haven't seen so
spoilers i got into the show weird i saw
serenity
uh because i during i think during my uh
time served working at blockbuster i
just like took it home one night and
watched serenity and then was like oh
this is neat and then
started firefly yeah and i have a
similar
relationship to it with lawn is like i
heard so much about it
i watched it there was a there was a
half attempt to watch it
uh many years ago and i i couldn't get
over the the
budgetary constraints frankly as uh this
was like
when marvel movies were coming out and
like netflix shows and stuff like that
and i was trying to watch firefly like
this looks like a laser tag arena
they're just kind of like
bumbling around with some second hand uh
stuff but then
this time sitting there and watching all
the way through like
you know that cast is really good and
they really really support each other
and they're really having a good time
and um seemed like a family which
apparently they were off camera too like
you can't fake the chemistry that they
all had
together so you would have just wanted
to watch them
hang out more um they had such good uh
it was such good casting and i think
that that elevates
and really informs like uh joss's
material like nathan fillion
is taking a character that i think
normally would be like a clint eastwood
like an a-hole type but it's just kind
of
filianized and is made into such a more
interesting like
warm uh fun to be around hero then i
think that most like
if he really was basing this on an old
western that character would have would
have sucked
so i appreciate it uh i like it a lot i
wish it had more time but i do think
yeah it is kind of like
the dot live fast die young thing that
it's kind of been mythologized because
it got cancelled so soon
part of me does also feel like if you
just totally reboot like same
same plot same characters same core
ideas but just rebooted it today as like
a hulu show
or a netflix show like it would probably
go for like the customary three four
seasons like i definitely think this is
like it is ahead of its time in that way
that if you just pitched firefly as an
original concept today
netflix would probably make it it would
probably get three years you'd wrap up a
lot of the plot
oh yeah considered like a successful
show 100
yeah business has changed it got
canceled uh uh i think in lieu of uh uh
fast lane i believe it was called on fox
uh yeah i think amber thiessen
um yeah oh yeah
but yeah they they didn't have to cater
to us nerds back then but we cater to
you
so let's watch our honest trailer for
firefly
from human thumb joss whedon the man
responsible for buffy
the avengers and the snyder cut comes
the groundbreaking sci-fi series that
got cancelled
but like traditionally cancelled not
joss whedon cancelled
firefly oh pause jess whedon
has not been he's currently making like
an hbo show or something like cancelled
cancelled it's funny where the people
like oh they've been canceled and
they're still getting paid
millions can we please check that the
title of this youtube video like
screen junkies cancels joss whedon
i'm alert dramaalert he's never gonna
work again
he works plenty he's fine yeah
yeah i don't i i actually the the
details are hazy uh
except that well there's the ray fisher
stuff because he's like abusive then his
ex-wife like
yeah he ruined the justice league
he wrote the pseudo cancellation fronts
that you've got to deal
he's the misogynist front and then
there's the ray fisher he did
terrible stuff on the justice league set
yeah either way not cool
or both in in both instances but it's
not i don't believe we've reached
official cancellation where
it's like pending right cancellation
pending
ending it's a culture keep going
return to a time when studios weren't
catering to a nerd's every women fantasy
in fact they couldn't even be bothered
to air this stuff in order
and explore a budget from the rift um
that's
that one's sort of that one's definitely
on fox but also i don't know
a two-hour pilot is pretty crazy
it's a crazy thing to ask a network to
show
a two-hour episode of television and
there and
and also incredibly stupid of the
network to be like so we'll just skip
that one
and start with the next episode i did
like the uh the weird
they feel i don't know if they actually
are but they feel slapped on because of
the out of orderness of it all
like the random character vo that sets
up every episode
that gets where nathan feelings like
okay here's the deal here's the premise
of the show here's what's going on
he's delivering it like the character is
bored of giving you the intro which i
really like all right here's what
happened
we were like the rebels yeah you know
where outer rim you guys have seen star
wars greedo just it's that it's that
you've seen star wars i'm han solo
there's some droids like i don't know
we'll figure it out
yeah all right keep going
and explore a budget friendly riff on
star wars i'm not playing anymore
anybody makes so much
here a twangy group of heroic rebels
fought a war for independence
against the alliance which i'm sure was
fought over
planets rights or something maybe don't
think too hard about the whole
confederacy and space thing
i'm thinking we'll rise again
suit up in your dustiest browns and
beiges with the crew of the serenity
a ship that looks like an ass-up
gizmoduck there's malcolm
wait can you pause on that gizmoduck
frame joe and i
uh disagreed i think that that's the
proper
way gizmoduck should have rotated i see
the head of the ship is the wheel of
gizmo duck
it's like a the broadness of the
shoulders represents the bulk of the
ship and then it
kind of like concatenates into into his
little wheel
let me reverse engineer you uh uh to the
position where
i think he should be flipped the other
way around uh
the joke for one thing uh thank you
spencer for allowing me to have a job
where i spent a very long time
discussing with
you guys what the ship looked like oh i
wonder if i can find in uh in slack what
the other things were there yeah we had
a lot
we had a lot of there was like a list a
lot of suggestions
and so originally i was like it looks
like
uh like a roast duck you know with like
the head still on but then i was like
that's also not funny
and so and then in my head it was like
well if you
cook gizmo tuck i guess you would look
similar
so like yeah the cockpit of the ship is
like gizmoduck's dead cooked head
yeah so we have we have a a roast duck
from joe
um i said pluck chicken then you said
gizmoduck taking a nap
uh and i also threw in there the uh the
bird mr burns has who looks like mr
burns but i really don't
think that
it really bothered me for like a day or
two
yeah yeah yeah it was a was a hot slack
channel for a minute
uh anyways uh you sound off in the
comments which way gizmo duck should
have rotated to
i also i also had uh darkwing ducks jet
which it does i urge you all to look up
dark wig ducks jet
uh a space pigeon santa claus on a
glider
or a direct-to-dvd starship trooper
sequel
surplus sale which was which made it in
as the
the armor because that was a second hand
we'll get to that
ship looks like santa claus on a glider
that's one more when it's flying yeah i
kind of have to look at it when it's
flying through space for this okay
claws on a glider but it does because
it's kind of fat in the middle and then
there's just like wings coming out
well again in the comments what does the
ship look like let us know
um okay let's keep going okay there's
malcolm reynolds
the captain who's quick on the draw and
even quicker to lose his temper
you're gonna get to that bridge and
you're gonna get us back on our feet go
keep a civil tongue in that mouth or i
will sew it shut
gag her if you have to go i'm gonna bow
remember i'll stick you back in your
crate
shut up i feel bad he makes everybody
cry
he's like a monster that's not a white
trash starscream
captain around i'm in charge the
autobots would have lost eons ago if
i've been calling the shots
no i'm in rotten charge here and i'm
telling you how it works i guess that
makes me the new leader
that's a concept you can't seem to wrap
your head around you're an
idiot starscream simon a cup of yogurt
i'll keep you going for a few more just
watch yeah that's going to say i have to
cut either
a transformers the motion picture or
a wrestling joke from every honest
trailer
and sometimes one slips through when
it's uh when it's long enough and
and you care deeply enough about this
one then
no more for a few months thank you
think screw it i think this one actually
really worked so uh
yeah he expect to see more of that i
didn't make the starstream connection
but once you did
it was like oh that of course that is
exactly
exactly his beat every time yeah
all right let me go i am captain now
simon
a cup of plain yogurt who's super into
his sister my sister's a genius
she was a gift i don't think my last act
in this verse is going to be betraying
my sister
shepard book who wasn't always a
shepherd you know how would a shepherd
know a name like that
when you look at these wounds i'd see a
54-hour sniper rifle they do a lot of
shooting at the abbey there shepard
one day you're gonna tell us all how a
preacher knows so that much about crime
my name is shepard
i don't think i noticed until we
actually put all the shepherd clips
together but i appreciate that it's
jane that's always on to him like the
crappiest
person uh yeah the most mistrustful guy
ever hired
yeah and i mean did they go into this in
the movie
what more of shepard's uh no
it's a recall but i don't think so i
don't think we ever get like a clue no
they don't he just
answered can we just spoil the crap out
of serenity in this video
is that okay yeah it's old it's fine
yeah he just gets murked in the movie oh
they all
basically well i guess it didn't matter
that two of them do yeah yeah
him and uh yeah okay
which i spoiled for a friend of the
channel erica ishii
in the worst possible way and i felt
better yeah well
you were sort of warned audience sort of
warned i mean this is
the most you can hope to get examples of
whedon like uh like taking western
tropes and like actually reforming them
in interesting ways like there's a few
times that he does that in this show
where it's like
that is a totally like western like the
the preacher who's got a dark past and
he's reformed and
you know like even it's like ross that
has the machine gun in it i was gonna
say it's even cheech marin's character
from like i believe the machete uh films
or
desperado desperado um so yeah that's
kind of fun when he sort of
recontextualizes that
actual western drug space all right
let's keep playing alan tudyk as himself
oh dear god in heaven and if you were
wondering if there were any female
characters
come on this is a whedon show the ship
has every kind of joss woman
the sexy fighting one okay people
if it moves shoot it the sexy adorkable
one
that's the buffet table well how can we
be sure
unless we question it the sexy uh
sexy one most of my clientele is male
do you know that and the sexy living
weapon with the brain of a child who
just woke up from a nightmare
because you do seem a little bit
[Applause]
river you know it's a shame this got
canceled after one season we'll never
know which one has a barren womb
do you like whippy dialogue i mean it
became like a parody of itself but like
i don't know for its time that was cool
josh just
justice has like the same three moves
that he keeps going back to yeah i
i prefer even though i love the avengers
and i really like buffy um
i prefer the world where this was a ten
season show to to him
um making every superhero movie or
setting the tone for every
superhero movie i i think that he could
have just
run with this cast and uh of women on tv
strong action-packed uh funny quippy
women and just kept going with that yeah
i i i've already seen sort of some
pushback where people are just like
uh you guys wouldn't have had this
problem with when the show came out and
or
everybody loved buffy or whatever and
sure but i think that's sort of the
the power of hindsight is like okay he
has
one move or you know a handful of moves
and
he makes them every time you know you
see the code now you're
seeing the code and we we have talked
about this before because it comes up in
luke bassan
movies as well the like infantilized
super weapon but men are constantly in
control of her and she's a captive
but she's an ass kicker she's so strong
but she needs our protection
yeah it's such a weird specific trope
and it
it does kind of keep popping up in this
stuff to the point that it's like
fetishized and a little weird so i think
that one might have jumped out at me
even in the
heyday of firefly but like no i mean
like gina torres character is a good
character
it's a little trophy but it's fun like
that that works and
i don't think there's anything like
offensive about that character it's fun
i think wash is a little bit of a life
guy as we sort
it's a of weird that he's just every
episode he's got to have like three
lines of dialogue like but she's my wife
but like otherwise so yeah it's less of
a criticism of the show and more just
like uh
and here is joss whedon bingo yes
exactly right
yeah i've got bingo all right keep going
do you like quippy dialogue then you're
in luck because if this ship falls under
50 quips an hour
it's rigged to explode strap in with
non-stop banter that would make kevin
smith and diablo cody's noses bleed
and then cheer on the talented cast that
makes it work turning every type of
possible quip into television gold
like sarcastic quips we'd always hoped
you two kids would get together
who is she snarky quips i think you can
stoop to being on my own
will you wash it first says equips that
sounds like something they hook up in
the movie
you live in a spaceship deer
no i don't think okay all right yeah
just thinking that's probably
season four yeah just a weird
aside and love to kevin uh
one of my favorite parts of this trailer
is when he says sassy quips and it's
just that shot of jane reading that book
like he's reading an old-timey joke book
i don't know it just makes me laugh
sorry to do a reading on someone all
right keep going oops that sounds like
something out of science fiction
you live in a spaceship dear and the old
joss whedon three step
someone makes a statement something
contradicts that statement funny
reaction
first rule of battle don't ever let them
know where you are
[Music]
they won't discover it till they go
order their next round of drinks wait
good drink or that one we're going back
oh that's a spicy weed climb aboard
serenity
for plenty long props to you for for
noticing that the jaws being three step
now and you'll never
unsee it oh yeah oh now that i've called
your attention to it every weed and
written thing you ever watch for the
rest of your life you'll be like oh he
did that he did that thing again that's
his favorite feed
and it comes from like you know he comes
from a family of
sitcom writers he's like third
generation sitcom writer like
what are you gonna do it's baked in like
that just that kind of comedy beat is
just instinctu
instinctual and look when you gotta move
you're gonna use the move
when you gotta move the works it's yeah
i mean that's exactly it is like it's
funny like so when you when you do it
and you get the timing right you've got
a funny
performer it works you know it sells the
moment
yeah but it is funny once you point it
out it's like that's a little creepy
whereas honest trailers never falls back
on the same
styles of joke moving on
the next segment the for plenty of
action in mayhem
as the crew takes a job what are we
doing oh
crime hopes the ship doesn't fall apart
you'll have enough to buy your own ship
better one than this piece of crap i
want every inch of this junker toss
junker you paid money for this sir on
purpose
what do you mean river pulls a weird i
can kill you with my brain
mal a flirt with an aura she's a horror
ship
they teach her that in horror academy
well i don't suppose you're the only
[ __ ] that dude
someone mentions actually it's horror
academy war is over
there's something wrong with you you and
manny fought in the war together right
someone bought here fought for the
independence i love the fact that you
two are old army buddies and they have
wacky stories with ribcages in them the
job goes south and everyone draws their
guns
someone gets almost dead
[Music]
yep he's dead and someone says something
to mal
he dramatically turns and repeats it
quietly to himself
long as we got good i call this win
right
we win and you know what it works
next thing i know i've got a brown coat
in the gorham officially licensed
monopoly game
yeah it is all on his shoulders right
joe
it really is i mean everyone's doing a
lot of work and i know everyone has a
lot of favorite characters but
and not to say that anyone's bad on the
show because i think they're all doing a
great job but nathan fillion
is the core the anchor the foundation of
the show
like everything else gets built on his
back yeah i feel so bad that
i mean i don't feel too bad for him but
it's like i think if
he or this show were around in the 80s
or 90s
he'd be a household name and like a
massive movie star
um and even the show itself like it's
not quite prestige but it's not total
pulp
either like he's he's just a man stuck
in the middle like he's too good for
sorry but like like a hercules style
like uh
serialized show but he's totally the
material is kind of like dragging them
down
or it's too broad to be like uh i don't
know a true detective
style performance so instead he's he's
got this and
and uh bones is it and boats
no castle castle oh i keep getting
no that was i think you're getting david
boreana
angel angel yeah who was angel yeah
excuse me
but yeah no you're right and i think i
think because of firefly
2 i think he got the um uh
from from the the biz he got kind of the
bruce campbell
treatment where they were like right
after this he was captain hammer
yeah yeah yeah um
but yeah no he's he's great and i i
think the
the main reason like that that i was
like really sold on making that like the
the last gag of that run is i think
that's the moment that really sells the
pilot
and really sells the character of mal
reynolds too like after the quips and
all of that like
he's just exhausted and sad and it's a
legit good moment that i think really
sums up the show
yeah all right let's wrap her up
vote in the gorham officially licensed
monopoly game so walk the verse for a
spell
with firefly the show that laid the
groundwork for so much of today's pop
culture
including how to throw tantrums if they
ever try to take our stuff away again
but ironically owes its legacy to being
taken off the air too
soon because let's face it on a long
enough timeline every fan would have
gone full reaver eventually
first season of firefly it was fine i
guess seasons two through five
not so much nathan fillion really needs
to do something new like a quirky crime
procedural
what exactly are you supposed to be
space cowboy
star james t work
i watched that episode just to see
joey's extraordinary punch list
jane and hats princess leia
zoe spationel
[Music]
i feel like we do that jim i'm a doctor
running no running away no running way
no running away no running test
i got no written idea you're a rutting
fool
brought lasers where's my rotten money
my sister's brain was a writing
playground
i love rutten because uh um it means the
same thing as the f word
right um it's a synonym it's just like
the yeah when uh when an animal
runs i i think we should actually start
using that now so 500
later at standard it's like you know
when it when a when a sea manatee gets
out on the beach and starts running with
its mate
it's it's less distracting than when
they come up with fake swears like
zorp like zorp few or frack well frack
made sense by the uh if you hear it
enough times but yeah
i think fracko frack also works uh it's
it's the
i i like i like the old-timey old west
slang in the show uh it does not make a
lot of sense though like
i get that they're on these planets that
are like new frontiers that are like
look western
but you know why why did like some of
the culture and technology just
jump back to the 19th century it's like
weirdly
it's almost like the idea is like like i
get that like
some of the you know like you might use
like a gas lamp again but why does it
look like a 19th century
like why wouldn't it look like a future
version of that that's right like the
the tech jump
like they explain it as nathan fillion
exhaustedly explains it at the top of
every episode you guys is that
they they terraformed a bunch of planets
and then everyone just got ignored
so they they just have to like make do
because they have no technology
and that why would again they'll look
like gasoline from old times
like sure maybe there's a railroad on
this planet but why are they going back
to saying
reckon that just because you build a
railroad doesn't mean you then have to
say wreck it
well you know if you find your second
you're like what that's that's
a cover all holding a pickaxe it just
like it takes on a life of its own it's
just like
things have progressed enough to where
all the slang is now
in shot like everyone knows mandarin and
yet they're still saying rotten and
reckoned
it doesn't make a lot well we don't know
what it doesn't make a lot of sense i
i think that so the alliance right is uh
is like america and china
uh uh combined at some point over the
next 500 years i can see a world where
like
we go through a big wild west revival
phase um
yeah the yacht the swing movement of the
90s like the swing movement of the 90s
is when the alliance forms
i mean you walk by a clothing store
right now and it looks like uh
it's all neon 90s stuff so i i can
definitely
just i'll get back into yeah in a couple
of years forever 21 is just going to be
10 gallon hats
the mandalorian is is what started it
all i mean we're all just going to be
uh old west space pirates can't wait
yeah the soggy bottom boys are back in
the rut and soggy bottom boys keep going
zac efron
gorham or something something this is my
god i'm dead
you're a gorilla i'm fed i'm gonna go
rampage the gorilla reapers followed us
we need some gorilla
support turn this moon into a gore ram
theme park shut my
core i'm like i don't give a good go
around about relevant washboard i don't
give a good gauram when you think
you're not my girl mine you're my gorm
ship
shiny you look shy that guy said gorham
is shiny shiny shiny shiny shiny
shiny and shiny goods and cargo
the goods must be intact this girl is
the smallest cargo i've ever had to
transport take the temperature
jane help me with the cargo cargo cargo
cargo goods
cargo cargo
it just makes them all sound like sword
guys
this makes them all sound like white
guys that have like too many
like katanas or chinese throwing stars
like on a wall ninjas it's a hard
language to do phonetically because
it's tonal like you you're basically
doing like you're singing it as you're
speaking it
and i don't know who was on set that day
checking the pronunciation but even if
there was someone it's it's just hard
you can't expect them to uh
it's americanized chinese it's like uh
it's like an orange chicken burrito or
something
i'm wondering how they did it in the
script like the writers would probably
go like
insert chinese in chinese yeah and then
they would have a chinese speaker be
like oh i know what they could say and
like teach the actor how to say i'm
guessing
they're all they're all real goofy
things like there's a website
actually that i've found that translates
yeah it has them all and it's all goofy
stuff
like what in the name of a dinosaur's
butthole and
stuff like that but that's fun um
we could have uh reached back out i
forgot to our uh our chinese translator
for the transformers for age of
extinction honest trailer
the last third of that is in chinese and
we had a lot of fun uh trying to
translate some
michael bay back
anyways let's keep going go the
[Music]
chinese people with speaking roles my
wife
mal she's my wife are you getting my
wife into trouble i'm not flying
anywhere without my wife
could you please tell my wife the fun
she's missing out on everything's laid
out if you'd like to cook for your
husband
[Music]
and welcome to the rough decks
secondhand roughnecks
just in space
okay this is what you were trying to
make let's see what you did
couldn't get a hold of no flour so it's
mostly protein
nailed it
[Applause]
very proud of this stupid joke yeah what
is that what is
it's mostly pro is it so it's like the
snow piercer
bug bars like that's what it's made of i
think so
yeah just like a protein starch you know
whipped together
right yeah yeah pretty gross yeah but
yes any excuse
to uh um to sneak nailed it in there
which i just find to be one of the more
delightful
reality shows on netflix yeah is uh
especially
you can skip the first there's no lore
to nailed it so just skip the first
season because
i think starting season two they just
they're just like
how did we get a season two fire yeah
the relationship between nicole byer and
wes is is multi-layered i do think you
kind of want to check out
yeah you want to see that art
oh man all right well thank you guys for
watching this far in the video
uh let's take one second to just tell
you to uh subscribe if you haven't and
to hit the like and the bell so you
never miss another one
in your life because we do it every week
and we will do it next week that's a
promise and a threat
um let's talk about the uh stuff that
didn't make the cut we have some
outtakes
uh some cut stuff let's roll it starring
han joko zapp brannigan that guy has the
right idea he wores brown coat
castle in the sky nathan that's really
good
uncharted space leave him alone
white guy wash number one make it so so
damn gina adam not actually a baldwin
make the alliance great again jane doe
deadwood pool only fans donatello does
machines
gadget hack wrench the good book the
renegades of monk
i'm trying ringo i'm trying real hard to
be the shepherd
hello my name is simon and i like to do
docking
sitting with a doc in a bay ring tam
grown-ups acting like kids curse your
sudden but inevitable betrayal
well maybe i should do that then maybe
you should okay
good fine space cowboys
twangy star wars gone with the whedon
money plane one season in a movie
okay well we i know we also cut even
from the cut things is
all the twangs uh uh strung out together
the guitar twangs
i think we were afraid of uh yeah
getting flagged but
yeah the soundtrack is fantastic um it's
such a good fit
uh very starcrafty in my head of like
you're looking at outer space with some
sweet guitar licks uh
and the theme song is is pretty
unimpeachable so the music is another
reason why i like it
um where are you saying joe it was
pretty baller
pretty baller pretty baller uh let's
talk about some let's take some comments
and questions uh scott pool writes i was
one of those people who didn't know a
dang thing about the show while it was
on
and caught on later i blamed myself for
the cancel should have given it a shot
when it was on
don't blame yourself man it's okay i do
i blame him yeah i blame you
yeah put all your trailed towards scott
poole
yeah this well this is well before um i
feel like
online campaigns are able to save things
and even those don't work anymore
uh i feel like when a studio is just has
it out for a show it doesn't matter how
many people all of a sudden jump on the
train that they're just gonna
they're just gonna end their show it's
it's like people trying to buy up stamps
right now to fund the post office it's
like no the studio is gonna cancel the
post office
yeah i mean i don't look it's it's it's
a joint
the there's joint blame because with
audience and studio because
they didn't have good ratings and i'm
sure this wasn't even though they cut
corners like it wasn't the cheapest show
to make like
they just weren't getting people but
then over time it built and built and
built that like
i wish that there was more patience on
the studio side because so many shows
don't take off like creatively until
their second or third season yeah but
we're also in an era now where a show
just owning
a show that goes for a few seasons
especially in a genre like sci-fi
it has inherent value because all these
companies own streaming platforms or
they want to
sell it on amazon or whatever and like
this was from an era where the show had
the value of
how many ads can we sell on it when it
airs this week and like
after that unless you thought it was
going to go into syndication and play
for years and years years
that was it that was all you were going
to make on that show so it's a very
different
like today if you were looking at season
one of firefly even if it didn't get a
lot of views you'd be like
well maybe it'll find an audience this
season too people love this kind of
stuff and it'll be worth it just to have
a few seconds of it to keep people
coming back to hulu or whatever
i think fox especially was rightfully
gun shy with
sci-fi at this point because i mean
there have been a few non-star trek big
hits battle star i feel like was a
pretty big hit
stargate obvi there's a million star
gates but like
fox had done like earth 2 and
mantis and the nightman and
uh front space frontier copper
like i feel like i'm just making big but
they had done a bunch
and um just gotten burned there
there's one that i remember uh was gonna
start following x-files
that uh they put a ton of like promotion
into i can't remember what it was called
uh but i remember a guy fights an alien
ship and sings the ramones while he does
it that's the only thing i remember
about the show okay
but i mean they had just dumped money
into a ton of sci-fi stuff
i think hoping to have another like
x-files style hit and
just wasn't working so i don't think
that this this doesn't happen
except this was more a favor to joss
whedon like what do you have after buffy
and uh
and um what was it angel and stuff like
that he's like sci-fi and like
okay so don't blame yourself blame the
failure of mantis
blame the failure of mantis and then
robert king uh chimes in it was released
out of order and had constant time slot
changes which doesn't do it
any favors uh james bunt writes there's
a great comic that goes through the
shepherd story told backwards
okay cool yeah i remember they did like
uh a couple some comics like
set between um the series and the movie
too that
handled the blue the glove hand guys and
all that
yeah uh sg rapness my my rap alias
right any other one season shows you
wish continued
anything else in the firefly vein of
like gone before its time
whoa one uh one one season is is tough
oh selfie selfie okay
delphi was great and then um uh
for me it's clone high but that is
coming back so we got him we got him
boys
you got your wish there yeah i mean
pushing daisy's got
two seasons so i guess it doesn't
necessarily qualify but that's always
one that i wish had gotten a chance to
continue oh a toucan birdie there we go
which is also very
yeah i think so oh
how nice somebody rescued it maybe that
would be delightful because
yesterday after one season and it was so
good uh surviving jack was a really
funny sitcom with christopher maloney
that i thought was
i mean he's brilliant uh that only got
one season it should have gotten renewed
okay uh speaking of recommendations and
stuff we like uh
yin feet yanji right uh there's so many
ways that could have been pronounced
i hope that was the right one uh shout
out to lon recently watched only lovers
left alive because he mentioned it and
it was great
so good i love that one it's that jar
moosh
vampire movie where they're tired of
being vampires we were talking about
during the old guard because it was like
wouldn't they get bored
jar machine yeah movie where they get
bored yeah yeah perfect
uh and then brent dreyer writes was
there a draft where he got into the
surrounding movie or is that maybe a
future trailer
uh there was no draft where we really
got into the movie in any way so
yeah it's also a universal movie and
universal gets real
funky sometimes with using their stuff
so i think uh
i think we probably would have cut any
serenity jokes from this one just to be
safe
we also forgot the ultimate one season
and cancel
great show ever freaks and geeks guys ah
yes oh yeah
all timer yeah um and not even a movie
or anything too bad
not not i hope those kids made it out
okay they seem
they seem cool that's sam levine up to
these days
uh all right well uh we will not be
doing uh serenity next week but we will
be doing something
uh equally incredible and amazing
and uh man you guys just gotta pucker up
for this one is it time oh yes
it's time to pucker up uh because we're
having a lot of fun next week
next week's on trailer uh if you don't
know about it ask
ask a teen because we're going there
and uh we will see you next week same
time same place australia commentaries
fan
entertainment thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you